Profesora Tamar Gendler: Muy bien.
Lo que quiero hacer en la
primera parte de esta clase
es terminar el análisis de
libertad de la última vez,
y comenzar diciendo un par de cosas
adicionales de aclaración
sobre las páginas específicas
de Nozick que leímos,
y luego avanzar a explicar lo que creo
que es una manera importante
de que Nozick y Rawls
confrontan uno de los problemas
que cada uno de los pensadores que
abordamos y confrontamos;
es decir, el problema de suerte al
determinar la experiencia humana.
Cuando terminemos con esto,
avanzaremos en las dos lecturas
empíricas que hicimos para hoy.
Así, recordarán que en las
páginas de Nozick que leímos,
éste se preocupa, antes que nada,
o presentar un marco general de
pensamiento de la filosofía política
en un concepto que dé prioridad a
la libertad y los derechos.
En particular, en las páginas que
leímos del capítulo siete,
se preocupa por expresar una visión
sobre la legitimidad de
poseer propiedades,
que tiene su justificación
principal en tres partes:
Recordarán que la primera es
el análisis de Nozick
de la noción de justicia
en la adquisición.
La última vez hablamos de las
condiciones bajo las que Nozick cree
que es legítimo que alguien
posea propiedades.
Aquí, la idea básica es que es
legítimo que alguien tome algo
del procomún que carezca de dueño,
en tanto no viole lo que Nozick
llama la provisión de Locke.
Es decir, en tanto alguien deje "tanto
y tan bueno para los demás".
Y consideramos dos
objeciones a esa visión.
Una, la idea de que hay un
tipo de desagrupamiento
que hace ilegítima incluso la
primera adquisición,
si a la larga la propiedad se agota.
La segunda se basa en el
problema de los comunes
que independientemente de que
vaya a haber un tiempo
en el que el que alguien
aparezca en desventaja
frente a otro que asume la propiedad,
y hablamos de las respuestas
que les da Nozick.
Espero que en las secciones de
esta semana ustedes
tengan oportunidad de pensar si esas
respuestas son legítimas.
Vimos las visiones de Nozick sobre
justicia en la transferencia,
que son básicamente cualquier
transferencia que dos personas
están dispuestas a comprometerse en un
tipo legítimo de transferencia.
A los ojos de Nozick,
restringir lo que se les permite a
ustedes hacer son sus propiedades
es una restricción
ilegítima a la libertad.
Pero Nozick reconoce,
y esto no lo vimos en la
clase del martes,
que además existe la necesidad de
un tercer tipo de noción.
Esta es la idea de que, a veces,
la propiedad se adquiere de
manera ilegítima,
ya sea al inicio o como consecuencia de
una transferencia ilegítima.
Con respecto de eso, bajo esta visión,
se exige a cada persona participar en
algún tipo de rectificación.
Esta idea da origen a un paso
bastante asombroso
al final del capítulo, que
leímos la semana pasada.
Nozick escribe que, de hecho,
hubo antes incidentes de injusticia en
la adquisición de propiedad.
Por ejemplo, esta nación se fundó con
base en los esclavos negros.
Nozick observa que quienes pertenecen
en el grupo menos favorecido
de la sociedad tienen ahora las
mayores probabilidades
de descender de las víctimas de
la injusticia más seria.
Como consecuencia, dice,
tal vez sea razonable usar la
siguiente regla básica.
Tal vez deberíamos hacer lo
que Rawls sugiere
y organizar la sociedad para
beneficiar a los menos favorecidos.
Las injusticias, dice Nozick,
pueden ser tan grandes
como para hacer necesario a corto
plazo un estado más extenso
que el que propone Nozick, a
fin de rectificarlas.
La página 231 de Anarquía, Estado y
Utopía nos dice que tal vez
una buena regla básica sea
organizar a la sociedad
para beneficiar a los menos favorecidos.
¿Después de todo, Nozick
y Rawls coinciden?
Observemos lo que Nozick afirmó antes.
Incluso si entramos en un acto de
reorganización temporal,
la libertad trastorna los patrones.
Así, dé a cada quien una
alcancía del mismo tamaño,
déles la libertad de hacer lo que
quieran con sus monedas,
y de manera inevitable a unos les
irá mejor que a otros.
Además, como observamos al final
de nuestra última clase,
estas distribuciones de riqueza pueden
terminar teniendo consecuencias,
donde decidir si violan por lo menos
el espíritu de la Estipulación de
Locke se convierte en una pregunta
muy difícil de responder.
Al final de nuestra última clase
observamos que podría
haber una sociedad
en la que haya una distribución igual
de la riqueza entre personas
y una interacción social entre ellas,
con respecto de las instituciones
que preparan a las personas a
convertirse en ciudadanos democráticos.
Pero si, como lo demostró la
última diapositiva,
es inevitable que tal estructura a la
larga tendrá como consecuencia
una distribución
desigual de la riqueza,
y si una distribución desigual de la
riqueza trae consigo la libertad
de optar por salir de ciertas
instituciones públicas,
crear otras privadas desde
las cuales sea posible
tomar recursos que alguna vez
pertenecieron a instituciones públicas,
luego en particular en el caso de cosas
como la educación y la salud,
que se podrían considerar
condiciones previas
para participar en la democracia,
se complica pensar si se justifican
estos tipos de distribuciones.
Así, la imagen de Nozick
nos presenta una idea
de los tipos de acciones
que se permiten.
Por un momento parece como si
Nozick coincidiera con Rawls
en cuanto a que se permite cierto
tipo de redistribución.
Pero a la larga no es el
aprovechamiento dentro del marco,
al menos en el sentido obvio, para
evitar situaciones como esta.
Ahora bien, es un tema abierto si
uno toma como prioridad
evitar situaciones como esta.
Pero un hecho asombroso en Una Teoría
de la Justicia y Anarquía,
Estado y Utopía, es que una
mirada a sus índices
no incluye referencias a la
educación ni a la infancia,
y sólo una conciencia
limitada del tema,
que será fundamental para
nuestro análisis de hoy.
Es decir, en las formas en que las
estructuras sociales que nos
rodean terminan afectando los tipos
de preferencias que tenemos,
además de los tipos de
opciones que hacemos.
Ahora, ustedes recordarán que
la pregunta fundamental,
que subyace en el debate acerca
de lo que hace legítima
una estructura particular en la
sociedad es la que expresó Rawls
al inicio de la Teoría de la Justicia,
que puse como el segundo tema
de ensayo para ustedes,
para el conjunto final de ensayos.
Rawls señala que una sociedad es una
"asociación cooperativa
para la ventaja mutua,
que se comercializa
típicamente por el conflicto,
lo mismo que por la identidad y
los intereses" y observa,
siguiendo a Hobbes en la
tradición del contrato social,
que hay una identidad de intereses
en la cooperación especial
que permite una vida mejor
de la que cualquiera pudiera
tener sin cooperación.
Pero [aclaración: también] un
conflicto de intereses,
ya que las personas no son indiferentes
a la distribución de estos bienes.
Ahora, en cierto nivel podemos concebir
un aspecto del debate entre Rawls y
Nozick, en el que Rawls dice:
si las cosas salen en el patrón
de una forma que no se querría
detrás del velo de ignorancia ,
intervengan y redistribuyan.
Nozick dice: si las cosas
salen como resultado
de las acciones libres
entre personas libres,
entonces, independientemente de cómo
luce el patrón, acéptalo.
Uno puede ver la diferencia en la
perspectiva entre ellos
como diferencia en la perspectiva acerca
cómo se nos requiere moralmente
manejar el hecho de que,
hasta ahora en cuanto a que
ocurren cosas que nos afectan,
determinar lo que está y no
está en nuestro control,
en tanto importe para nuestras
reacciones internas a los eventos,
como señaló Epicteto.
En la medida en cuanto importa
a nuestra tendencia a responder de
acuerdo con nuestros comentarios,
como cuestionaron Aristóteles y
Doris, en su debate con aquél.
Y en la medida que cubre nuestra
atribución de elogio y culpa
en los casos de delito o
acierto no intencional,
que las discusiones de suerte moral y
el castigo, y Kant contra Mill
o si hay un mérito moral de
salvar a un niño.
En todos estos casos, la pregunta
fundamental que se hace es:
¿qué tipo de paso es apropiado
para los seres humanos,
dado lo que dice Epicteto,
"algunas cosas son nuestra
decisión, y otras no lo son"?
Así, si vemos la Teoría de
la Justicia de Rawls,
leemos los siguientes y
asombrosos pasajes.
Rawls dice, "Los dos principios
mencionados", es decir,
el primer principio que dice que los
derechos no son superables,
hablando en términos amplios, cada
persona tiene derecho a ciertas
libertades básicas, que ninguna
cantidad de utilidad puede anular.
Y el segundo principio, que dice
que las desigualdades
han de distribuirse como
resultado de oficios abiertos
por igual para todos y de tal
forma que las desigualdades
puedan beneficiar al menos favorecido.
Rawls dice, "los dos principios
mencionados parecen ser
un acuerdo justo sobre la base de
quienes están mejor dotados
o más afortunados en su
posición social,
ninguno de los cuales puede
decirse que lo merezcan,
podría esperar la cooperación
dispuesta de los otros,
cuando algún esquema funcional es
una condición necesaria
para el bienestar de todos".
O de nuevo, "una vez que decidimos
buscar una concepción de justicia
que nulifique los accidentes de
la dotación natural
y las contingencias de las
circunstancias sociales
en la búsqueda de una ventaja
política y económica,
nos guiamos hacia esos principios".
Una vez más, "estos principios
expresan el resultado
de hacer a un lado esos
aspectos del mundo social
que parecen arbitrarios desde un
punto de vista moral:
los cosas que no puede decirse
que nos merecemos".
Accidentes de la dotación natural.
Contingencias de la
circunstancia social.
Aspectos del mundo que
parecen arbitrarios
desde un punto de vista moral.
Rawls participa en el viejo
proyecto de pensar
cómo manejar la suerte moral.
Y debido a que la distribución
de bienes y ventajas,
tanto dentro de uno mismo como
entre las personas,
en muchas formas no es
decisión de nosotros,
Rawls concluye que los
principios que expresa
en la Teoría de la Justicia son
lo que la justicia ordena.
Por contraste, a Nozick también
le preocupa la suerte.
Veamos los pasajes al final
del capítulo siete.
Aquí, dice Nozick, hablando acerca
del texto de Rawls, tenemos
la razón de éste para rechazar un
sistema de libertad natural.
Permite que las acciones distributivas
reciban influencias inadecuadas
de factores muy arbitrarios desde
el punto de vista moral.
Nozick dice: Rawls trata de resolver el
problema de la suerte moral.
Estos factores, dice, citando a Rawls,
son la "distribución anterior de
talentos y habilidades naturales
que se desarrollaron a lo
largo del tiempo
en circunstancias sociales y
contingencias aleatorias
como el accidente y la buena fortuna".
Observen, dice Nozick, que a
Rawls le preocupan cosas
que no son decisión de nosotros.
Pero no hay, dice Nozick, mención
alguna a la forma en que
las personas eligieron
desarrollar sus activos
naturales.
Y es al reconocer a la contraparte
de algunas partes que no son
decisión de nosotros:
es decir, el hecho de que algunas
cosas son decisión de nosotros,
que podemos ver la noción de
Nozick del postre legítimo
a la luz de este eterno debate.
Esta línea de argumento, dice
Nozick criticando a Rawls,
pueden tener éxito al bloquear la
introducción de las opciones
y acciones autónomas de una
persona y sus resultados,
solamente atribuyendo todo lo que
valga la pena sobre la persona,
a ciertos tipos de factores externos.
Pero, dice Nozick, si comenzamos
a pensar en las personas
definidas por sus circunstancias
en la forma que sugeriría
una extensión lógica de
esta visión, pero,
"denigrar la autonomía y la
responsabilidad básica
de una persona por sus acciones
es una línea arriesgada
para la teoría que de lo contrario
desea apuntalar la dignidad
y el auto-respeto de los
seres autónomos".
Regresamos a la pregunta fundamental.
Dado que somos seres influidos por
el mundo a nuestro alrededor
en formas extraordinariamente
difíciles de entender,
¿en qué medida merecemos el crédito
para el que nos percibimos como
de manera voluntaria?
¿En qué medida nuestros caracteres y
circunstancias están unidos
de manera tan inexorable con cosas
más allá de nuestro control
que pensamos desde la
perspectiva de nosotros
como deseadores de la estructura en el
mundo es un error completo?
Así, quiero señalarles que lo que
comenzó luciendo como un debate
acerca de la legitimidad
de los impuestos,
termina viéndose como uno de nuestros
debates filosóficos centrales.
Una vez más, nos
confronta nuestro estado
como seres en el mundo al que
afectamos y que a su vez nos afecta.
Así, ese tema en dos artículos
empíricos particulares
es lo que quiero abordar en los treinta
minutos restantes de la clase,
en el contexto del análisis de
estructuras sociales.
Así, recuerden que en esta unidad
de filosofía política
comenzamos con una lectura del
Leviatán de Hobbes
y encontramos su argumento que,
debido a ciertos hechos acerca
de la naturaleza humana:
básicamente nuestro deseo de
controlar los bienes a nuestro
alrededor y las limitaciones en el
número de bienes que hay,
estaremos en un estado de guerra
de todos contra todos
en la naturaleza.
Y luego vimos una
representación matemática de
ello
en la forma del dilema del prisionero
y luego consideramos dos
respuestas particulares
en la tradición angloamericana
occidental del siglo XX:
Rawls y Nozick,
para reflexionar cómo se ve
una sociedad legítima
en el contexto de los hechos acerca
de la naturaleza humana.
Lo que quiero hacer en la
parte de la clase
dedicada a las estructuras sociales,
es traerles la forma en la que las
estructuras que nos rodean,
terminan determinando nuestras actitudes
por lo menos tanto como nuestras
actitudes terminan determinando
las estructuras sociales a
nuestro alrededor.
Este tema ya estaba
presente en Aristóteles.
Así, en las páginas finales de
la Ética a Nicómaco,
que leímos hace aproximadamente
un mes, Aristóteles,
en un capítulo llamado Transición de
la moralidad a la filosofía
política, observa, "si los argumentos,
por sí solos, fueran suficientes
para hacer decentes a las personas,
las recompensas que obtendrían
habrían sido muchas y grandes".
Pero "no es fácil alterarlo con un
argumento" que desde hace tiempo
se absorbieron como resultado de
los hábitos propios.
¿Cómo entonces, pregunta Aristóteles,
podríamos cambiar a las personas
si los argumentos solos
no son suficientes para hacer
decentes a las personas?
Bueno, señala, es difícil para alguien
estar entrenado correctamente
en su juventud si no crece
bajo leyes correctivas.
Porque "para los jóvenes no es
agradable vivir con templanza".
Es por esa razón que una de las cosas
de esta antigua imagen de
gobierno, una de las cosas
que la ley debe prescribir es su
crecimiento y las prácticas.
Porque si se usan para
comportarse de ciertas formas,
no les parecerán dolorosas.
Así, Aristóteles habla de
una función de la ley
que nos ocupará hoy y el
jueves: la función de la ley
para dar forma al carácter de las
personas a quienes rige.
Pero no encontramos este tema
sólo en Aristóteles.
John Stuart Mill, autor del
famoso trabajo De la libertad
y también autor de Utilitarianismo,
que leímos para esta clase,
habla mucho en el mismo
sentido que Aristóteles.
Escribe, al hablar de cómo
estructurara apropiadamente la
sociedad,
de modo que se maximice la
cantidad de utilidad que genera,
dice, "la utilidad impone que
la primera de las leyes
y los arreglos sociales deben
colocar la felicidad o,
hablando prácticamente, podría
llamarse el interés, de cada persona
tan cerca como sea posible en armonía
con los intereses del todo".
Una sociedad bien estructurada, desde
el punto de vista de Mill,
administra la relación entre la
persona y la comunidad.
Y la utilidad se impone al mantener con
que, dice Mill, que la "educación
y la opinión, que tienen un poder tan
vasto sobre el carácter humano,
debería usarse para establecer en
la mente de cada persona
y la asociación indisoluble
entre su propia felicidad
y el bien del todo".
"La educación y la opinión, que
tienen un poder tan vasto
sobre el carácter humano".
Ése es el nombre de la clase de hoy.
Y dentro de aproximadamente
cuatro diapositivas
sacaremos los marcadores, porque
más adelante en el semestre
voy a querer que se despierten.
Así, si sacan sus marcadores,
les diré algunos hechos
y luego ustedes pueden darme respuestas.
Muy bien.
Así, el primer texto que leímos
para hoy es un largo artículo
de encuesta de la publicación
Ciencias Conductuales y del Cerebro,
en el que los autores investigan un siglo
de investigación antropológica
y psicológica en un intento de
traer la fuerza empírica
a la reclamación que Mill hace aquí:
la educación y la opinión,
y las estructuras culturales,
tienen un vasto poder sobre
el carácter humano.
En este documento, los autores
afirman que los sujetos,
a quienes llaman WEIRD: ciudadanos
occidentales (Western),
Educados, Industrializados,
Ricos y Democráticos;
es decir, personas que aportaron la
consciencia en una sociedad
que tiene estas cinco características.
Afirman que estos sujetos son
atípicos; es decir,
difieren en formas fundamentales en
su actitud hacia el mundo,
si se les contrasta con
sujetos que vienen
desde sociedades no
industrializadas de pequeña
escala;
con personas que no vienen de
sociedades no occidentales;
con personas que vienen
de otras sociedades
industrializadas occidentales,
e incluso con otras personas
de su propio país,
que no poseen educación universitaria.
En particular, afirman los autores,
los dominios en los que podemos ver la
rareza (weird significa raro --T),
en letras minúsculas, de los
WEIRD, en Mayúsculas,
es que la atipicalidad de los
ciudadanos occidentales,
educados, industrializados, ricos y
democráticos incluyen, afirman,
percepción, categorización, memoria,
atención, cognición espacial,
conceptos propios, juicios de justicia,
tendencias hacia la cooperación,
el conformismo, los
juicios morales, etc.
En un vasto número de dominios,
incluyendo aquellos de ustedes que no
son de culturas occidentales,
difieren de la vasta mayoría
de los 6 ó 7 mil millones de
habitantes de la Tierra.
Y la certidumbre de la vasta mayoría
de aquellos que han vivido en la
Tierra en cualquier época.
Como resultado de las experiencias
culturales que han tenido,
se afectaron su percepción y
capacidad de comprensión,
así como sus patrones de atención.
Así, los autores
escribieron su artículo
teniendo en mente un
objetivo en particular.
Lo escribieron en un
esfuerzo para afirmar
que la investigación psicológica del
tipo que llena las publicaciones,
incluyendo la que lo hizo
con este documento,
deberían basarse en muestras de
población más amplias.
Y establecen su argumento
porque se preocupan tanto
con la posibilidad de revelar las
deferencias entres seres humanos,
formas en que las personas crecieron
en un tipo de circunstancia
difieren de las personas que
crecieron en otra.
Y debido a que les preocupa
profundamente asimismo
identificar las formas en que
hay puntos en común.
Observarán que mientras
leen este artículo,
cada una de las cuatro
secciones principales comienza
con una serie de contrastes
entre los tipos WEIRD
y cualquier grupo de
contraste que se les ocurra,
pero cierra con un conjunto de
puntos comunes identificados
entre ambos grupos sugiriendo,
al menos prima facie,
que hay similitudes muy
arraigadas, presumiblemente,
como resultado de presiones evolutivas.
Pero este curso no es de
psicología evolutiva.
Este curso ni siquiera es
específicamente
de metodología de la psicología.
Entonces, ¿por qué leímos este
artículo? Por cuatro razones.
La primera es que este es un
curso que, como saben,
se llama Filosofía y la Ciencia
de la Naturaleza Humana.
Y este artículo,
tal vez de manera más densa que
cualquier otro artículo que recuerde,
contiene una vasta cantidad de hechos
sobre las formas en que
podrían ser las personas.
Así, la primera razón por la que
leímos este artículo es aprender
algunos hechos sobre la diversidad
y la similitud humanas.
Además, como saben, este
es un curso "y".
Este curso, como recordarán,
desde la primera clase,
que trata de reunir diferentes
perspectivas sobre las preguntas.
Una de las cosas que creo que este
artículo hace muy bien,
en particular en conjunto con el segundo
artículo que leímos para hoy,
es darles un rango de herramientas
para pensar en las preguntas centrales.
Una de las cosas en las que este
artículo los desafía a ustedes
es cuando observan una
conducta y la generalizan
con base en preguntarse
qué tan generalizable es esa conducta.
Pero este curso también, y
es la tercera razón
por la que leímos el artículo,
les presenta, como ya saben,
a un tipo muerto el martes y a la
ciencia cognitiva el jueves,
y el día de hoy es un martes honorario.
Así, la tercera razón que
este artículo hace
es hacerlos conscientes de
una crítica en vivo,
que se hizo el año pasado:
el artículo se publicó
hace menos de 12 meses
para hacerlos conscientes de
una crítica que se une
a parte de la base de
investigación del curso.
Una de las cosas que hemos hecho
a lo largo del semestre,
y una de las cosas que les instruí a
hacer en el ejercicio cinco,
fue echar una mirada a
algunos artículos,
cuyas muestras limitadas
cuestiona este documento.
Por último, leemos este documento
en el contexto de nuestra sección
de filosofía política
en una clase llamada
estructuras sociales,
porque me parece crucial,
si alguien quiere participar en
filosofía política seria,
aportar el complejo rango
de consideraciones
que necesitan reflexionarse acerca de
cómo deberían estructurarse
las sociedades.
Así, lo que quiero hacer en la parte
siguiente de la clase es analizar
tres ejemplos de los tipos de causas de
que trata el artículo WEIRD.
Tres causas en las que se
hace una reclamación
que la experiencia ha afectado la
percepción del mundo.
Comienzo con la más dramática.
Tal vez no es la mejor establecida.
Hablaremos de ello.
Pero la más dramática de
las afirmaciones.
Quiero que saquen sus marcadores
y vean estas cosas.
Y me digan si los dos
segmentos parecen ser tales
que la parte superior es más
corta que la del fondo,
o podría ser tal que ambas
tengan la misma longitud.
Hablamos aquí solamente de los
segmentos de línea.
O bien, ser tal que el inferior sea
más corto que el superior.
Tomará 10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 4, 3, 2, 1
segundo para ver cómo
surgen estos números.
Así, 41% de ustedes piensa
que la parte superior es más
corta que la inferior.
A 46% de ustedes les parece que
tienen la misma longitud
En tanto que para 14%
el inferior es más corto
que el superior.
14% de ustedes, tienen razón.
El inferior es más corto
que el superior.
¿Quieren verlo de nuevo?
Muy bien.
¿Qué ocurre aquí?
En la próxima diapositiva
tengo la misma animación,
porque no estoy seguro que
ustedes pudieran animar
una diapositiva que tiene gráficas.
Pero resulta ser que pueden.
Muy bien, veamos esto de nuevo.
Son idénticos. Son copia uno del otro.
Los hice y los medí,
porque tengo un programa de
medición en Power Point.
Así, este tiene 3.1 pulgadas
y este tiene en realidad 3 pulgadas
de longitud en la creación.
Así, el inferior es más
corto que el superior.
Se ha afirmado que la tendencia de
ustedes al percibir esta línea,
cuando se incrusta dentro
de esta figura,
en tanto este segmento más largo se
incrustó en esta figura,
es el resultado de haber crecido
en un entorno con ilusiones ópticas.
Y la reclamación se hace con base en
la investigación realizada
en la década de 1960 en una gran
cantidad de comunidades
pequeñas y no urbanizadas, que la
discrepancia entre las longitudes
de las líneas y de los segmentos, que
se requieren a sin de ver ésta,
tienen la misma longitud en tanto
que esta es extremadamente
diferente en sociedades de
pequeña escala en las que,
en principio y de acuerdo con
esta investigación,
no hay tendencia a considerar
en estas extensiones.
Para la sociedad occidental: esto es
Evanston, Illinois y Sudáfrica;
una tendencia a encontrar esta
ilusión atractiva masivamente.
Ahora, es complicado determinar si
estos datos se sostienen
a la larga o no, porque la investigación
se realizó hace casi 50 años,
cuando las herramientas para
hacer estas preguntas
se apegan a diferentes normas, que las
personas cumplen hoy en día,
no obstante es poco plausible pensar
que esto podría ser verdad.
La experiencia determina
este tipo de cosas.
Y no es inimaginable que, entre las
cosas que podrían determinar
es el tipo de
características
perceptuales
que se eligen al enfrentar
una situación.
Por lo menos, es innegable que
existen diferencias fundamentales
e interesantes entre la
tendencia de aquellos educados
en las culturas occidentales para
aprovecharse a sí mismo
de los dos tipos de
razonamientos fundamentales
disponibles para todos nosotros.
Así, saben, tanto por sus
lecturas de hoy
como de las relativas a la
tradición del procesamiento doble
a principios de este semestre, que
los seres humanos son capaces
de lo que se conoce como
proceso holístico.
Esto es orientarse hacia un objeto
incrustado en un contexto,
prestando atención a las
relaciones entre el objeto focal
y el campo que lo rodea y
tener una tendencia
como resultado de hacer
predicciones y ofrecer
explicaciones
con base en estas
propiedades relacionales.
Ése es un tipo de pensamiento.
Todos nosotros lo tenemos disponible.
Además, hay un segundo
tipo de pensamiento,
disponible para todos los
seres humanos adultos:
proceso analítico, a través
del cual uno se orienta
hacia un objeto considerado
de manera aislada,
presta atención primaria a los
atributos de los objetos,
no a características de su entorno
y exhibe una tendencia a predecir
y explicar los eventos
con base en tales atributos.
Así, recordarán que cuando
leíamos la crítica de Doris
sobre Aristóteles y se
hizo la sugerencia
de que no presenta a la
persona en sí misma,
ni atributos del objeto, que
determinan cómo es que alguien
actuará en una forma
potencialmente demandante.
Pero más bien
presenta su relación en este contexto.
Si encontró una moneda en
una cabina telefónica
o si tiene prisa.
La afirmación que hace Doris al ofrecer
esa crítica de Aristóteles,
una versión de lo que llama error
fundamental de la atribución,
es que hay casos en los que el
procesamiento analítico nos tuerce
y el procesamiento holístico lo
explica de mejor manera.
Asimismo, hay casos en los que
enfocar profundamente nuestra
atención en el propio objeto
y no atender los aspectos
irrelevantes presentan el entorno
nos dejará mucho mejor.
Es asombroso que, dado que parece
haber diferencias confiables
y estadísticamente
significativas a lo largo del
tiempo
en los miembros de las culturas
occidentales y no occidentales
con respecto del cual estas
actitudes se toman por defecto.
Así, en una serie de artículos escritos
a lo largo de la última década,
Richard Nisbett y varios
colaboradores presentaron a sujetos
con pistas como la siguiente.
Se les muestra una serie de peces
contra un fondo específico.
Luego se les muestra una
serie de peces nuevos,
ya sea contra el mismo
fondo o contra otro.
O bien, una serie de osos polares o
alces contra un fondo específico
y luego objetos novedosos o
previamente no vistos,
contra un fondo similar o diferente.
Así, ¿qué ventaja
demuestran los objetos
cuando ven un objeto que vieron
antes contra un fondo conocido?
Para las personas japonesas,
a quienes Nisbett y sus
colaboradores aplicaron la prueba,
un objeto se percibe contra
su fondo original
tiene un alto índice de precisión.
Si lo muestran sin un fondo,
hay menos precisión.
Y si lo muestran contra un fondo nuevo,
hay una asombrosa diferencia
en el desempeño.
Y una vez más con los lobos.
Si lo muestran contra el fondo
original, alta precisión.
Muéstrenlo contra el fondo nuevo, y
habrá una disminución significativa.
Estos son patrones limpios.
¿Qué le ocurre a los
sujetos occidentales?
Un patrón del todo diferente.
El fondo original no ayuda con
la reidentificación.
La falta de fondo ayuda mucho.
Se retiró la distracción que supone
la información adicional.
Y un fondo nuevo no es mucho
peor que el original.
Lo mismo ocurre con los lobos.
El fondo original produce alguna
ventaja, pero no mucha.
Voy a saltar el ejemplo siguiente,
lo que sugiere que ustedes
podrán ver esto por sí mismos en
las diapositivas que publico,
que una vez más son contextos en
los que muchos occidentales
parecen ser mejores en tareas absolutas,
y los no occidentales en las relativas.
Ahora, ¿qué tipo de beneficio
tenemos con estas generalizaciones
acerca de las culturas?
¿Hacerlo no es indignante?
La afirmación es que la
cultura no lo determina todo
acerca de una persona.
La afirmación es meramente la
poco sorprendente de que
crecer en circunstancias en
las que su atención,
por cuestión de curso, se dirige
en una forma particular,
los llevará exactamente en las formas
en que Aristóteles sugirió, p
ara encontrar formas de responder que
sean naturales y habituales.
Así, en los cinco minutos de
cierre de la clase
quiero darles un ejemplo final
del documento WEIRD.
Analizar algunos de los casos en
los que afirmamos que los
estadounidenses sobresalimos en
relación con otros occidentales
en los fenómenos que se asocian con
auto-conceptos independientes
u sobre los que se basa el
individualismo.
Todas estas son preguntas del marcador.
Y son una serie de
preguntas de encuesta que,
por lo menos hace 15 años, de manera
típica producían respuestas
muy diferentes en los sujetos
educados en Norteamérica
de lo que hicieron en ciudadanos de
otras naciones industrializadas
occidentales y no occidentales.
Es particular, respuestas diferentes
entre los estadounidenses
de las que se produjeron entre
alemanes, australianos o japoneses.
De modo que voy a darles una
serie de preguntas.
Vamos a ver cómo salen los números.
Y los compararemos contra su
apariencia en los estudios originales.
Esta es la primera pregunta.
"Mientras hablan y
comparten una cerveza",
yo sé que ninguno de
ustedes lo hará jamás,
que es algo que se imaginan
hacer para cuando crezcan;
"cando hablan y se toman una
cerveza con un amigo
que está oficialmente trabajando
como controlador de seguridad
en la empresa en la que ambos
trabajan, ocurre un accidente
y un compañero de turno
acaba lesionado.
La Comisión Nacional de Seguridad
inicia una investigación
y se le piden sus evidencias.
No hay otros testigos.
¿Qué derecho tiene su amigo de
esperar que ustedes lo protejan?
A, definitivamente tiene derecho.
B, tiene algún derecho.
D, no tiene ningún derecho.
Así, comisión investigadora,
¿protegerían a su amigo?
Veamos cuáles fueron los resultados.
8% de ustedes piensa que hay
un derecho definitivo.
48% de ustedes piensa que
tiene algún derecho.
44% de ustedes piensa que no
tiene ningún derecho.
Muy bien, veamos si podemos obtener
de nuevo estos números.
¡Dios! Muy bien, iba a decirles
de qué manera se comparan
sus números con las cifras
tradicionales que se verificaron.
Voy a dejar estas diapositivas
para ustedes, como siempre,
y pueden ir y verificar su comparación.
La idea es que, en los
estudios originales,
los estadounidenses mostraron, 94%
de ellos en esta columna,
y ustedes mostraron 92% en estas dos.
Si vieron en los otros países,
las personas dieron
diferentes respuestas.
La reclamación no es una o la otra de
estas perspectivas es la legítima.
La reclamación es sólo para
alertarlos del hecho
de que existen diferencias radicales
en la forma en que las
personas perciben el mundo.
Probemos la próxima.
Así que no sé por qué tenemos
aquí la revelación.
Así que no presten atención a los
números que aparecen aquí.
¿Piensan que "el único objetivo real
de una empresa es ganar dinero?
O piensan que B, una empresa
además de ganar dinero,
tiene la meta de lograr el bienestar
de los diversos participantes,
como empleados, accionistas y demás"?
Sus números sugieren una
tendencia a pensar
que tiene también otras metas.
Pero 33% de ustedes piensan
que la única meta de una
empresa es la utilidad.
Entre los ciudadanos japoneses
entrevistados en 1993,
solamente 8% opinó lo que
33% de ustedes opina.
"Si solicitan un empleo en
una empresa", piensan,
"¿uno, que es casi seguro que
trabajarán en ella el resto de su vida?"
¿O bien piensan que "están casi
seguros de que la relación
tendrá una duración limitada"?
Veamos cómo lucen.
8% piensan que trabajarán ahí
el resto de su vida.
92% que tendrá una duración limitada.
Por contraste, si ven los
números aquí,
están con los estadounidenses.
60% de los japoneses a quienes
se les hizo esa pregunta
dieron la misma respuesta que ustedes.
Una y otra vez, y les dejaré tres
ejemplos más a mirar en la diapositiva,
ya verán a quién se parecen,
si ustedes son como los
japoneses con 41%,
fueron diferentes de los
estadounidenses;
si fueron como los
estadounidenses con 99%,
fueron diferentes de los japoneses:
el entorno cultural en el
que se encuentran
desempeñará un papel al
determinar su perspectiva.
Comenzaremos la próxima clase
con una exploración de una
versión particular de esto
en el contexto del análisis de Cass
Sunstein de las normas sociales.